imagínate que vas al mercado a conseguir
un poco de fruta fresca en el momento en
que vas a pagar te das cuenta de que el
cliente que atendieron antes compró
cinco manzanas y cuatro naranjas por
diez pesos mientras que tú compras cinco
manzanas y cinco naranjas por 11 pesos
pregunta podemos encontrar el precio de
cada manzana y de cada naranja
resolviendo un sistema de ecuaciones
lineales con dos incógnitas si es así
cuál es la solución si no es posible
cuál es la razón de que no se pueda y
bueno para resolver esta pregunta lo que
se me ocurre que hagamos primero es
nombrar a nuestras variables así que voy
a decir que sean am x igual al precio de
las manzanas el precio de las manzanas
es lo mismo que x y por otra parte voy a
decir que es igual al precio de las
naranjas al precio de las naranjas muy
bien y ahora vamos a intentar escribir
con ecuaciones estos dos datos que yo
tengo el primer dato que tengo es que el
cliente anterior
a 10 pesos por 5 manzanas y 4 naranjas
es decir que 5 porque son 5 manzanas por
el precio que va al de cada una de las
manzanas 5 por x + 4 por el precio de lo
que vale cada una de las naranjas es
decir james esto tiene que ser igual a
10 pesos 5 x + 4 james tiene que ser
igual a 10 pesos es lo que nos dice
nuestro primer dato ahora a mí me
cobraron 11 pesos por 5 manzanas y 5
naranjas entonces 5 por el precio de lo
que vale cada una de las manzanas y
recuerdan que x es el precio de lo que
vale una manzana por lo tanto 5x es el
precio de lo que valen las 5 manzanas
más 5 por james es decir 5 naranjas por
el precio de lo que vale cada una de las
naranjas esto me tiene que dar igual a
11 pesos esto me dice que es igual a 11
pesos y bueno ahora lo que nos preguntan
es si podemos resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones y si es posible cuál es la
solución y si no cuál es la razón de qué
no se puede resolver ahora te cuentan
que a mí me parece que sí tiene solución
porque tenemos distintos coeficientes
para xy para allí en las dos ecuaciones
si tuviéramos los mismos coeficientes
para x y para jane luego luego podemos
concluir que no además la otra cosa por
la cual me suena que sí tiene solución
es porque una no es múltiplo de la otra
si me tomo una de las dos ecuaciones y
la multiplicó por cualquier constante
nunca me va a dar la otra entonces
parece ser que este sistema de
ecuaciones si tiene solución
ahora para encontrar la solución lo que
voy a hacer es multiplicar por menos la
ecuación de abajo entonces éste me queda
menos 5 x menos 5 y menos 11 y ahora voy
a sumar las dos ecuaciones para
resolverlas por el método de suma y
resta o de eliminación así que vamos a
sumar la parte izquierda de estas dos
ecuaciones y la parte derecha de estas
dos ecuaciones y que me va a quedar 5 x
5 x estas dos se van se cancelan
perfecto después me queda 4 james menos
5 y esto es lo mismo que menos james y
del lado derecho
10 - 11 esto es lo mismo que menos 1 y
ahora ya tengo que menor y es igual a
menos 1 y de aquí se multiplicó ambos
lados por menos 1 me va a quedar que ya
es igual a 1 perfecto y queda claro el
precio de las naranjas es decir que cada
una de las naranjas me costó un peso
ahora no hay que olvidarse que el precio
de las manzanas y para sacar el precio
de las manzanas voy a sustituir el valor
de james en la primera ecuación y tengo
que 5 x + 4 por jim pero lleva de 1
entonces voy a poner más 4 por 1 esto es
lo mismo que 10 esto tiene que ser igual
a 10 visto sustituyendo el precio de
cada una de las naranjas que ya lo sé
vale un peso y de aquí obtengo que 4 por
unas 4 así que voy a restar 4 de ambos
lados de la ecuación así que me va a
quedar y déjenme bajar un poco la
pantalla porque estos dos se van a
eliminar me va a quedar 5 x es igual a 6
5 x y del otro lado me va a quedar 10
menos cuatro lo cual es 6 y ahora para
obtener el valor de x voy a dividir todo
entre 6 todo entre 6 y así voy a obtener
el valor
de equis y no no no no no esperas pero
espera no es en 3 665 mi cerebro está
bastante dormido todavía perdón era
entre 5 para sacar el valor de x de tal
manera que se encuentre 5 se van y
solamente me queda que x es igual a 6
quintos déjenme bajar un poco la
pantalla para escribirlo x es igual a 6
quintos que por cierto esto es lo mismo
que un entero un quinto que por cierto
esto es lo mismo que 1.20 es decir que
cada manzana costó un peso con 20
centavos un peso con 20 centavos 1.20 de
peso y bueno la respuesta es que si si
podemos encontrar la solución